an x-files star hulking out blade
becoming the black panther these may
seem like deep pulls from the far
recesses of the multiverse but they came
closer to our reality than you might
imagine keep watching for more actors
who were almost avengers
the mcu was practically built on robert
downey jr's shoulders but he wasn't
always a shoe-in for iron man after the
actor's history of drug and alcohol
abuse landed him in prison studios
considered him to be box office poison
and a risky investment for future movies
you know who isn't risky business tom
cruise in fact cruz has been one of the
most bankable stars in hollywood for
decades while he claims he never came
close to playing iron man marvel chief
kevin feige said in 2004 that the studio
had been talking to the actor since the
late 90s but no deal was ever made many
assume it all came down to money and
while the then fledgling marvel studios
couldn't afford crews they could afford
robert downey jr it was a risky move at
the time but downey's casting has worked
out pretty well for both sides the
actors rap scallion wit and heroic heart
of gold have not just defined the
character but the mcu as a whole
basically no rdj no mcu and tom cruise
concurs too having one set of downey's
performance i can't imagine anyone else
in that role and i think it's perfect
for him honestly you'd struggle to find
anyone who disagrees
tom cruise may have been the most
bankable movie star to circle the role
of tony stark but he wasn't the only one
one actor who came especially close to
donning the red and gold with sam
rockwell who was previously best known
for movies such as lawn dogs and the
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy if
there's anything more important than my
ego on this ship i want to go out and
chat right now in fact iron man director
and mcu producer john favreau personally
asked rockwell to audition for the role
alas it wasn't to be though it's not
like rockwell hasn't enjoyed a pretty
remarkable career since 2008 most
notably winning an academy award for his
turn in three billboards outside ebbing
missouri he even got his chance to play
in the mcu sandbox having gyrated his
way into the role of justin hammer and
iron man 2. and with the character
rumored to appear in the upcoming armor
wars series it seems like rockwell may
not be done with the marvel universe
just yet
before chadwick boseman donned the now
iconic mask of black panther wesley
snipes set his sights on playing
wakanda's warrior king in the mid-1990s
snipes was enjoying some serious box
office clout after a string of hits and
wanted to bring black panther to the big
screen believing it could be a
blockbuster and cultural milestone
recently snipes told the hollywood
reporter black panther is an iconic
character who much of the world was
unfamiliar with and the communities that
i grew up in would love
snipes was right too he was just a
quarter of a century too early in the
mid 1990s batman was the only superhero
making movies cgi wasn't ready to
realize wakanda and marvel even declared
bankruptcy in 1996 to make matters more
difficult when studios heard the name
black panther they thought of 1960s
social revolutionaries rather than
superheroes snipes used the experience
to launch the highly successful blade
franchise while black panther itself
became the highest grossing domestic
superhero release nearly three decades
later and snipes couldn't be happier he
said even though i am not a part of this
particular project i support it one
thousand percent and i am absolutely
convinced that it will be a catalyst for
change and open other doors and other
opportunities
over the years the role of bruce banner
has seemed like a never-ending game of
musical chairs after eric bana and
before edward norton the front runner to
take the role was fox mulder himself
david duchovny banna who starred in ang
lee's hulk in 2003 dropped out of the
franchise when he discovered the sequel
was said to be straight to dvd
decompany's front-runner status was
revealed by marvel's then vice chairman
peter cunyo back in 2006. how close
duchovny came to getting the part is
unclear however all we know is that he
obviously didn't get the role and that
the straight-to-dvd sequel to lee's film
was scrapped altogether instead edward
norton got the part in the incredible
hulk which basically rebooted the
franchise into the new continuity of the
mcu after the successful debut of iron
man a year earlier norton famously got
himself fired from the franchise soon
after leaving marvel on pretty bad terms
he was subsequently replaced by mark
ruffalo who has played the part to
perfection ever since
oh go
bruce
damn
bruce listen to your mom
she knows better
marvel has evidently wanted to work with
emily blunt for some time now the
british born thespian has apparently
been offered not one but two critical
roles in the mcu peggy carter in captain
america the first avenger and black
widow in iron man 2. of course the
former part went to haley atwell while
scarlett johansson has been a key player
in the avengers movies and beyond ever
since her mcu debut there are many
reasons blunt didn't take the widow role
and she herself has claimed it was all
down to scheduling conflicts she refuses
to discuss parts she didn't accept in
detail however saying it's unfair to the
actors who ended up playing them still
there are plenty of female rules still
to come in the ever-expanding marvel
universe so fingers crossed blunt will
turn up sometime in the not so distant
future
emily blunt wasn't the only member of
her household to almost appear in the
mcu her husband john krasinski very
nearly donned the red white and blue of
the star-spangled avenger captain
america as his role as jack ryan has
proven he's more than capable of playing
a patriotic super soldier but it wasn't
marvel who pulled the plug on krzyzinski
playing the part it was the actor
himself according to krazynski he got as
far as a costumed audition during which
he saw chris hemsworth walk by in full
thor regalia in that moment brzezinski
realized what he was about to get
himself into and had a change of heart
chris hemsworth walked by his door and
he's like that night and i went i'm good
this is stupid
that's okay i'm not captain america
krasinski's decision may seem like
madness to many but if you've ever
watched a behind-the-scenes video of
actors wearing 100 000 halloween
costumes and staring at 10-foot tennis
balls surrounded by green screens you
can probably see his point and hey chris
evans is nothing to be sniffed at either
how's this for sibling rivalry before
chris hemsworth was cast as the god of
thunder in 2011's lore his younger
brother liam was one of the frontrunners
for the part early in his career the
tall and lanky chris hemsworth had been
having trouble finding parts that suited
his frame when he spotted a call sheet
for thor that required an actor of at
least six three and two hundred pounds
hemsworth auditioned for director
kenneth branagh and thought he nailed it
but he didn't hear back for months
meanwhile his little brother liam still
back home in australia had sent in a
taped audition and was subsequently
called back several times liam was one
of the final five in fact when chris's
manager contacted the movie's casting
team reminding them liam had an older
brother chris got another audition and
must have impressed this time as he was
cast in the role soon after
as hard as it is to imagine anybody but
chris pratt playing peter quill
guardians of the galaxy director james
gunn had a back-up plan for the part he
once told gq there was a good chance
that if i didn't cast chris that i would
have cast glenn howerton in the role
howerton most famously plays the morally
reprehensible dennis on the long-running
fx sitcom it's always sunny in
philadelphia a character who is about as
far away from star-lord as you can
possibly get
i am untethered and my rage knows no
bounds
while howerton would have done a fine
job as peter quill he arguably lacks the
movie star gravitas with which chris
pratt helped send guardians into the box
office stratosphere had howerton played
star-lord guardians of the galaxy likely
would have been widely regarded as a
quirky under the radar space romp
destined for cult classic status
somewhere down the road instead with
pratt in the lead role it became a
surprise smash and one of the most
successful franchises in the marvel
pantheon
before he was the king of atlantis jason
momoa was almost drax the destroyer the
actor had previously played barbaric
brutes such as conan the barbarian and
call drogo in game of thrones making him
seem like the perfect fit for a
character like drax but this was the
main reason why he didn't take the part
momoa didn't want to be typecast as a
brutish heavy hitter and especially
didn't want his kids to see him
miserable in his work as a result that
said mamoa did enjoy auditioning with
chris pratt later revealing
one of the funnest auditions i've ever
done in my life was with him mamoa is
also cool that wwe world champ turned
hollywood heavyweight dave bautista got
the part he said i think it's perfectly
cast dave is perfect for that role for
drax momoal would eventually get into
the superhero game himself taking the
lead in aquaman and becoming one of dc's
most successful cinematic heroes in the
process
two of hollywood's biggest comedy
heavyweights were also up for membership
in the guardians of the galaxy jim
carrey and adam sandler while still
early in casting for the film marvel
checked on the availability of each of
them it is uncertain however whether
both actors were up for the same part or
for different roles understandably there
was speculation that they were up for
the roles of rocket raccoon and or groot
as marvel true believers know those
parts eventually went to bradley cooper
and vin diesel respectively though it is
fun to consider what carrie and sandler
might have brought to these characters
would carry's rocket raccoon have had
the same mannerisms as ace ventura could
sandler's groot have said i am groot in
a voice similar to bobby boucher
one man said he wanted to decapitate me
nobody else thought that to be too bad
of an idea all anyone can do is
speculate still it's fair to say things
turned out well in the end
having first appeared in a mid-credit
scene of captain america the winter
soldier scarlet witch has gone on to
become one of the mcu's stalwart
characters even landing a full series of
her own in one division for the whole
time the character has been performed by
elizabeth olsen but she wasn't the only
one up for the role in fact the part of
wanda maximoff was reportedly originally
offered to bronx-born dublin raised
actor circa ronan when ronin allegedly
passed on the part it went to olsen and
given the massive success of one
division on disney plus the growing
world and spin-offs that came out of
that series and her connection to one dr
steven strange it appears that olsen
will continue cashing in her marvel
checks for some time to come
back in 2013 when edgar wright was still
attached to direct ant-man there were
two actors in the running for the part
of the miniature marvel paul rudd and
joseph gordon-levitt gordon levitt was
just one year removed from playing a
version of robin in christopher nolan's
final entry in the dark knight trilogy
the dark knight rises at the time
variety reported that he was one of the
final two actors being considered for
the part alongside rudd who had a series
of leading roles in comedic hits under
his belt that may have been what gave
rudd the nod in the end as wright was
apparently pushing for an even more
comedic tone than the other marvel
movies however gordon levitt later
denied he was ever in the running saying
the rumors were nothing but lies either
way it's all water under the bridge as
paul rudd has returned for two sequels
to ant-man and a number of other mcu
movies to boot
of course it wasn't just the title rule
that was up for grabs when edgar wright
was still spearheading ant-man two-time
academy award nominated actress jessica
chastain was rumored to have been
offered the role of the movie's female
lead while sources originally speculated
the rule was that of original wasp janet
van dyne it's now obvious that she
likely would have played janet's
daughter hope a part which ended up
going to evangeline lily janet of course
would eventually be played by michelle
pfeiffer in 2018's ant-man and the wasp
an actor of jessica chastain's caliber
certainly would have given the
light-hearted action-packed bug-centric
gromp some gravitas much like hollywood
legend michael douglas did in the role
of dr hank pym maybe we'll see her in
the mcu somewhere down the road
academy award-winning actor joaquin
phoenix was apparently not only in the
running but the front-runner to play the
part of marvel's favorite sorcerer dr
steven strange marvel wanted phoenix for
the role so much in fact that he was
rumored to be in final negotiations
before talks broke down according to the
acclaimed actor it had nothing to do
with marvel's more mainstream brand of
entertainment he later explained i think
they make some great fun movies i enjoy
those movies sometimes and i think they
keep the industry going in some ways so
i don't have a problem with it at all i
think everybody was really happy with
how things turned out all parties were
satisfied basically we have no idea what
the issue was but in any event phoenix
didn't take the part and it went to
benedict cumberbatch instead phoenix
true to his word that he has no problem
with comic book films later played the
genre's most infamous villain in joker
in the late 1990s pretty much every
actor who could convincingly play
spider-man was considered for the part
sometimes convincingly wasn't even a
consideration and some unusual choices
outright lobbied for the role from
charlie sheen to michael jackson
obviously not all of these people were
seriously considered in the 2000s
however toby mcguire put on the mask for
three movies before being replaced by
andrew garfield in the amazing
spider-man films cut to 2015 and
spider-man was being recast this time
for the mcu again everybody under the
age of 22 was under consideration and
among the final choices were asa
butterfield and tom holland spoiler
alert holland got it even so butterfield
isn't disappointed later telling
collider every so often there's a part
that you really want and you don't get
it and it is tough and it is
but i often find that something even
better comes out of it at the end and so
in the case of spider-man i did sex
education
it's hard to picture anyone but samuel l
jackson as nick fury but apparently
jackson wasn't the first actor
approached in fact that honor goes to
george clooney honestly you can actually
kind of see this working especially if
they were going for the great temple
skirt-chasing 1960s styles super spy
version of the character and clooney
even considered taking the role at least
enough to pick up a copy of fury the
2001 comic written by garth ennis that
however turned out to be a big mistake
clooney was reportedly horrified by the
absurdly violent series apparently the
scene that particularly killed clooney's
interest in the mcu involved fury
strangling a man with his own intestines
meanwhile mark miller and brian hitches
the ultimates had already reimagined
nick fury as a certain iconic hollywood
star and so in a case of life imitating
art samuel l jackson was given the part
robert downey jr and gwyneth paltrow go
together like salt and
well
pepper
however the academy award-winning
paltrow was not iron man director john
fabro's first choice for the part of
pepper potts in fact the director was so
high on his main choice that the iron
man script was sent exclusively to
favreau's favorite rachel mcadams back
in the mid-2000s mcadams was still
basking in the warm afterglow of mean
girls and the notebook and consequently
had her pick of parts evidently iron
man's love interest wasn't high on her
list of priorities though apparently the
time traveler's wife was
i wouldn't change anything
while mcadams wasn't to play a part in
marvel's inception she later took the
role of steven strange's love interest
dr christine palmer in doctor strange
and is due to return in doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness perhaps
master of mystic arts is more her type
than billionaire military arms
industrialist
among the most prized of all female
superhero roles are characters such as
wonder woman catwoman and storm but
after the multi-billion dollar success
of the marvel cinematic universe
lesser-known characters suddenly came
into play as potential blockbuster
heroines one of these was carol danvers
otherwise known as captain marvel 25
years ago danvers was most famous to
comic book fans as the superhero who
x-men character rogue put into a coma
when she stole her powers now her
popularity rivals that of wonder woman
that's quite the turn around before
oscar winner brie larson snagged the
part however a few other big names
wanted to play captain marvel at a press
junket for jurassic world bryce dallas
howard revealed that she wanted to play
a part in a marvel movie when
interviewer eric eisenberg suggested
captain marvel howard responded yes
let's start a campaign now that would be
rad another actress who shared her
enthusiasm was olivia wilde when
meadowland director reed murano tweeted
to the film's star olivia wilde that
they should work on captain marvel
together while tweeted back oh hell yeah
let's do this well we can't say either
howard or wild we're almost captain
marvel we can be reasonably sure that
they would have jumped at the
opportunity check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you